Speaker 1: All right. Now let's talk about some
of the vile corporate media reaction to Joe Biden
just getting us out of a place we
shouldn't be anymore. It's been 20 years
insane cost in terms of dollars and lives.
We're getting out. We're getting out. And that's
the right thing. And it should have been handled
better. Some things were not done correctly. Biden
took responsibility yesterday. The corporate media
seem almost war thirsty. I'm going to play some
clips for you from yesterday's press briefing
moments after about a half, three point five,
30 minutes after Joe Biden spoke. Jen Psaki,
the White House press secretary, took questions.
And during that question and answer period,
it seemed as though the corporate media in the
room is already interested in what's the next war
and maybe will go back in. There were questions
about what maybe will do something to North Korea.
A very, very strange. And I think there's a couple
of reasons that we're seeing this, which I'll tell
you in a moment. Let's start with the first clue
Speaker 2: into the president's decision,
any situation in which he might deploy a
large amount of U.S. troops abroad under
Speaker 1: his presidency. And the tone
of the question is, is it's almost like
they're saying Joe Biden seems so opposed to
military incursions. I mean, is there anything
that will get the guy to fill some country with
American troops again there? Because there should
be. I mean, the tone is just stunning here.
Speaker 2: Sort of foreign competition require
a sort of mass troop deployment that
he just said we are trying to go.
Speaker 3: I think one of the pieces
that he talked about in the speech was
how he views our engagement in the world. And
I think this is probably why you're asking this
question and the horrible scenes and memories
of the last few weeks. And as we think about
how we embark on or how we use military force,
these moments and these divisions of the last
several weeks or months or years should
stick in us and he may stick in our minds.
Speaker 1: Can do you understand what's going
on? Joe Biden is ending a 20 year conflict and 25
minutes after he decisively explains why he
did it. Reporters are almost indignant saying
this guy willing to send troops anywhere. I
mean, what the default should be. We don't
send troops everywhere. That has been
American foreign policy for too long.
Here's another clip where a reporter says, why was
Biden mad? Biden seemed mad, but more importantly,
would he go back into Afghanistan, where
we've been out for like 12 hours, guys?
Speaker 3: He seemed angry at the beginning of the
speech today. It matter, I would say I'll go, I'll
give you a different assessment of what I saw,
which is that he gave a forceful assessment,
laid out a forceful case to the American people
as to why it was time to wind down a 20 year war
that has led to the loss of thousands of
lives. And in his view and I think he made
a firm case of this, it's not in our national
security interest to be on the ground anymore.
Speaker 1: The follow ups included which
which I'm not even going to get to now.
What are the circumstances in which we would
go back in? Guys, we've been at that point,
we had been out 12 hours and you're talking about
going back in. So I think there's two different
things going on here. One, there are some
reporters who just by nature want to be seen as
asking the tough questions. And when something as
rare as a president decisively saying, we are out,
it's over, we're we're withdrawing, we're coming
back, we're not deploying, we're coming back.
That's rare in American foreign policy to do
it so decisively and so so definitively that
the way to be sort of tough and contrarian is to
talk about the opposite. This isn't a president
who will shy away from deploying troops, right?
It's not. And they just don't realize how war
thirsty they sound as if the default should be.
The U.S. should just be picking places to send
troops. That's one piece of it. The other part
of it is that it's almost cliche at this point.
It might even be apocryphal. Like I don't even
know what this like isn't even really true. But
there's the idea that conflicts mean controversy
and controversy means ratings and that, you know,
that's probably a factor to some degree,
although I don't know how much of a factor it is
to the reporters, but to some of these news
institutions, that's probably a factor. Bizarre.
We're almost in a bizarro world, but I would
rather a bizarro world in which what is being
done is pulling troops back. And the bizarre part
is the media saying, shouldn't we go more places
than the opposite in which we are just sending
troops everywhere? And then we have to be the
voices saying this is this is a bad idea. I would
rather the reality be we are pulling troops back.
Let me know your thoughts. You can find me
on Twitter at David Pakman. Remember that
The David Pakman Show depends on the support
of folks just like you, people who listen to
the podcast, people who watch a YouTube clip here
or there, who watch the hour long show on YouTube
every day, listen on the radio, watch on free
speech TV. You can sign up at join Pakman dot com.
And I hope that you will.